belly you remember Billy Black yeah
you're looking good oh I'm still dancing
you are
you are quite the actor on the screen
another iconic and chest that you've
been a part of was Twilight yeah so 15
years ago
15 years well I was just a pup and
you're still just but you kick things
with it I mean talk about fandom right I
mean what do you recall from being a
part of that franchise and a memory that
just really sticks out most to you I
think the fanaticism of it you know of
just becoming part of Pulp culture and
um you know I think that's those are the
days when people fans were camping out
five days before the movie opened and
developing that community that they
shared and loved so much with that that
franchise
uh and every actor you know dreams of
having something that that's popular you
know they're they're creating something
that that the fans really love so yeah
it was it was a fantastic experience and
look at you you're striking it twice
striking iron twice with two incredibly
successful franchises oh blessed am I
incredibly I'd say so let's go for three
from Twilight to Yellowstone Gill
birmingham's character Thomas rainwater
has been dutton's rival from the start
and now this season which debut Sunday
on Paramount Network he might just have
to make a deal with the Devil
is this a good thing or a bad thing
he'll kill the hotel
and kill the airport
it's a good thing for the land
but I don't see how it's good for us
not yet anyway
yeah I think they both have a deep
respect for each other because they have
a connection to the land they both want
the same thing different reasons
um
but John's throwing a curveball in it
right now in this season and that's
going to ruffle some feathers and
you know necessitate some some
reassessment and realignments and a
little bit of ambiguity you'll be
surprised how quickly you'll replay all
your moments in life in your mind you
guys have a heck of a lot of fans a lot
of faux gloves and yellow stuff yeah
what kind of fan encounters have you had
what would be one of the most memorable
ones that comes to mind
um
I'm thinking I did a trip through
Yellowstone National Park and uh I
stopped at one of the sites there
waterfall went driving down the road
about 10 minutes
and this woman recognized me and she
actually followed me on down to the next
spot
and then the next spot the next spot was
she didn't she didn't get a chance to
ask for a picture so my partner got out
of the car before I was even out of the
car she said you know let me take a
picture with me and she goes well this
lady wants a picture with you and I said
I haven't even got another car yet how
does she even know it's me
she was hot on your heels I mean
[Music]
foreign